the hell was that dip just dip under man
what's wrong with you listen to anything
I say put your knees down
stick your chin up stick it up there see
what you're doing you're down the hit
you I damned hit me hey hit me hit me
now
got the Train huh hotter than the other
man if you want to win that's what I
installed in my fight all right I don't
have a regular regimen per se I got my
own style
yeah my own philosophy you want to be
prepared for war I'm you mean you don't
like it hey I'm not gonna be it'll be a
[ __ ]
to finish a gazebo
god damn yeah man I don't think I don't
hear the rumors about me Oh people are
always talking about Teddy I got eyes
and ears everywhere man
you know people saying oh you know
that's hello he's crazy you know you
can't train a fighter like that well you
know what I say this is a Ted alone
scroll to boxing man they don't call me
the tagged actor for nothing
outta my way man see I like apples when
they caramelized but the crust has got
to be thick you know nothing make me
matter and thin crust you ready
you know Gatorade was invented at the
University of Florida for the Gators
right don't have to be a Florida
graduate a hydrate know everybody yeah
I've never even went to town